après les violences affrontements entre
les forces de l'ordre et les
manifestants antibacines samedi dernier
à Sainte Soline des rassemblements ont
lieu devant les préfectures de chaque
département ce jeudi soir pour dire non
aux violences policières une initiative
notamment de la Confédération paysanne
dans le centre-ville de Tours on
retrouve romain d'alville pour prendre
le pouls de ce rassemblement qui va
débuter mais qui pourrait bénéficier
d'une convergence des luttes Romains
oui bonsoir Hélène bonsoir à tous Alors
nous sommes en effet place Jean Jaurès
la prise de parole des différents
syndicats on est toujours en inter
syndicale au moment où je vous parle
avec la CGT la FSU il faut la CFDT
solidaire sont bien sûr présents ce soir
nous sommes aussi nombreux que la soirée
où Elisabeth borne avait décidé
d'appliquer l'article 49-3 avec cette
petite notion en plus c'est que la
moyenne d'âge a été rajeuni car derrière
nous beaucoup d'étudiants ont rejoint
justement ce rassemblement alors nous
allons d'abord évoquer ce rassemblement
qui continue contre la réforme des
retraites pour le deuxième
rassemblement place de la préfecture là
où c'est plus compliqué c'est qu'en
effet la elle n'a pas été déclarée et il
risque d'y avoir certains blocages
beaucoup de syndicats ont décidé de ne
pas y participer les jeunes pour
certains mineurs ont décidé de ne pas y
participer je suis avec Franck Leroy du
syndicat solidaire d'Indre-et-Loire
parlons tout d'abord des retraites on en
est où dans le mouvement on en est où
dans la contestation est-ce qu'elle
s'essouffle bah continue en tout cas de
se mobiliser la preuve aujourd'hui
encore c'est un peu là au pied élevé
donc c'est pas mal le rassemblement
aujourd'hui c'est pour pas laisser
tomber justement le soufflet et on
espère que toute façon le 6 avril il y
aura encore plus de monde que la
dernière fois dans la rue donc on
continue on lâchera rien
le deuxième rassemblement auquel vous
allez participer en tant que solidaire
en tant que syndicat solidaire place de
la préfecture il est contre les
violences policières peut-être celle qui
ont été qu'on a pu voir sur les réseaux
sociaux à la télévision en particulier à
Paris ou dans d'autres grandes villes
lors de manifestations contre la réforme
des retraites et puis bien sûr sainte
Soline la semaine dernière oui tout à
fait il y a de plus en plus on voit que
le note président
se cache derrière une muraille de
policiers et ça devient très embêtant
pour vraiment emmerdant pour pour
manifester il y a des atteintes tous les
jours il y a des étudiants à Tours par
exemple qui sont arrêtés totalement
arbitrairement qui finissent en garde à
vue c'est fait une politique pour faire
peur on voit aussi au travers de
beaucoup de médias des choses aussi par
rapport
internes dans la police sur le ils sont
inside dans la police et ils font ça
tout l'après-midi sur j'ai fait on voit
ça moi ça me franchement ça me révulse
voilà et là par exemple on a eu une
ébornier à Rouen on a eu un camarade
cheminot aussi qui a été bornier on a eu
plein d'étudiants qui ont été évidemment
arrêté arbitrairement et on a eu aussi
évidemment sainte Soline ou plus de 4000
grenades ont été balancés
aux manifestations les manifestants avec
plus de 200 blessés une quarantaine de
blessés graves et deux qui sont toujours
entre la ville à mort et ça on ne
l'accepte pas
Macron il est toujours président mais à
mon avis il continue comme ça il va pas
rester longtemps ben voilà Franck Leroy
solidaire et Sud solidaire toujours
aussi déterminé en effet comme je vous
le disais en inkipit cher Hélène le la
manifestation le rassemblement place de
la préfecture ce n'est pas encore assuré
qu'il puisse avoir lieu peut-être
sera-t-il bloqué par des forces de
police car il n'a pas été déclaré ce
soir
merci qui vous accompagne